let's talk about news and there's been
some interesting studies really released
recently that people are not watching
the local news anymore I don't know how
they're going to find out that cat three
blocks away from them got electrocuted
or that you know the neighbor fell off
the roof or all that kind of stuff but
basically people are turning to tune it
out thirty-one percent of respondents in
this pew survey said they've stopped
watching local news altogether and
basically people are only tuning in now
for weather new sports and traffic now
David I want to start with you here
because you're you're a news guy do you
think this is just a sign of the times
is this just everyone going to the
internet for this stuff or is it that in
local news it's just absurd you just see
you know the neighbor that got hit by
the car there's just such a non-stop
negative situation attached to local
news that people can take rizal let's
hit non-stop you know I've been doing
local news for the last 10 years and
what I hate the most of people go I
don't watch the news cuz it's so
negative no [ __ ] can we say both you
can see those no [ __ ] because you
love the negative you love the gossip
and you love the blood and gore so
that's sort of a pet peeve of mine it is
true that the numbers are shrinking but
it is because we all walked in here with
a phone and we all have a Twitter
account and that's what we're all
checking it's why I left local news
after ten years to go and do something
that was on a digital platform but I
will tell you this when it rains people
watch the news when they are stuck in
traffic you know they that's when local
news will never go away is it dwindling
shore but doesn't matter if you're in
Bangor Maine or Los Angeles you're gonna
watch your local news yeah so weather
traffic sports Brian are you gonna miss
the absurd stories like just you know
just the craziness bloopers yeah you'll
say something outrageous and everyone
post on YouTube no I love the local news
always turn on the early morning before
you know like the Good Morning America's
and the Today Show's all come on I
always turn on except with LA it's
always like a little like oh and we'll
talked about Lindsay Lohan's latest
quarter period yeah this is on the local
news but yeah I do like the local next
your way I ran has the ball
but that's right but no I I do
definitely like the local news it says I
don't know if it's just a generational
thing but it feels very safe and it
feels very you know you feel very in
touch with your community rather low
where do you get your news I mean what
the thing is you're saying generational
and you know I think has happened as I
think that in this generational shift
we've become more obsessed with pop
culture and what's happening like you
said with lindsay lohan as opposed to
you know what's happening on the local
government level or anything like that
you know we we are obsessed with these
stories so you know Us Weekly is is
selling out and people aren't to an end
unless it affects their beach community
well actually what you're talking about
is something that we've talked about on
every episode of this show this idea
that pop culture has sort of infected
everything else we do to the point that
it so II all our news is wrapped up in
pop culture everyone wants to stop this
book how do we do it what do we actually
do besides talking about you're not
gonna stop it you know why because
people keep tuning into it we make fun
of Lindsay Lohan but I promise you when
you go back and look at those numbers
today when she was in there gonna be off
the charts for lohana yeah it we relate
to celebrities we relate to their drama
we relate to them being late we relate
to them recklessly driving and lying to
police we relate to that okay I haven't
lied to put was like the other you said
too much well yeah senegal o'hare court
appearance make you feel better by your
own problems maybe the government
stories i get there hard to tell as a
journalist it's hard to make you care
why a community in southern california
is is 600,000 in the red and why their
city manager got arrested you guys
already look forward right people don't
care about those kinds of stories but
when somebody throws a glitter bomb at
lindsay lohan walking in before a
headline and then she snored as she
thinks it's the new designer cocaine
that's a start
don't forget the official outfitter of
the Reuben report is bonobos calm enter
code TR are 20 for twenty percent off
your next shirt